[Music]
we can up every day's first thing you
think and I will just moko Jumbies
is right hidden chillin at the tradition
of moko Jumbies is a special form of
stilt-walking named after a West African
spirit who watches over villages thanks
to his towering height
in times of celebration groups of
Trinidadian dancers pay tribute to the
spirit but for Adrienne loco Jumby is
part of his everyday life
my name is Dion young and I've been
walking stilts for 21 years the highest
I walked isn't it my dance group is
called future Jumbies and it's a school
for anyone to learn to walk stilts the
imperious wins do put on yesterday we
got our shoes attached and then we have
a nice tie up and then we can have
someone raises up between starting on
one foot steps and then they gradually
[Music]
these are the dance move on still we cut
limbo stoop lara butterfly and the mocha
tree in the hottest movies the a split
that's where you take a fatality me my
favorite part of moko Jumbies dancing is
when my whole team that i trained just
killing it I feel a joy back then doing
nothing when I see my team giving a day
all and doing their routines I feel a
sense of pride and sometimes feel like
sharing at it now by sense of bringing
everyone together
you
[Music]